et j - 3 avant le début du Salon de la
grille culture il s'ouvre ce samedi sur
le site Paris Expo Paris Porte de
Versailles et toute cette semaine nous
ont des focus sur les représentants Yves
Linois qui seront sur place en rappelant
que les Yvelines sont le deuxième
territoire agricole en Île-de-France les
producteurs sont donc au rendez-vous et
ce soir nous avons en plateau le
fondateur de l'huile riz et de la plaine
de Versailles c'est Christian Hubert
alors chez les Hubert d'ailleurs
l'agriculture c'est une affaire de
famille hein ça se transmet de
génération en génération tout à fait
donc mes grands-parents étaient
exploitants donc c'est réalisé de
producteur de grande culture tout comme
mes parents et bah j'ai repris le
flambeau avec une particularité de
transformer nos produits pour ne plus le
vendre justement à l'exportation mais le
garder sur le territoire mais justement
je vais faire une petite transition avec
euh
donc notre objectif n'est pas de
d'exporter par contre si on prend le cas
des lentilles aujourd'hui les trois
quarts partie viennent du Canada
ce qui est une aberration totale ce que
d'une part on sait les produire j'en
parlerai tout à l'heure mais d'autre
part on apporte un modèle agricole qu'on
ne veut pas c'est de la déforestation
c'est de l'OGM c'est du glyphosate et ça
devient le bout du monde alors pourquoi
les importer du coup pourquoi parce que
c'est peut-être un peu moins cher et
surtout je pense
on sait pas que dans les Yvelines on
peut faire pousser ses plantes et
qu'elle pousse bien et qu'elles sont
bien la cuisson qu'à son bonnes
savoureuse et finalement il y a rien à
voir avec ses lentilles du Canada ça va
continuer le côté agriculture chez
l'univers vous essayez de le transmettre
aussi oui on ne force pas mais si la
passion est là chez nos fils pourquoi
pas et avec plaisir mais il y a il y a
de quoi faire il y a de beaux projets à
relever donc ils sont jeunes mais
pourquoi pas alors vous êtes tournés
vous autour de la production de blé de
colza d'orge vous travaillez avec une
trentaine de producteurs de terrain du
territoire on va en parler dans un
instant et vous êtes aussi tourné vers
les légumineuses pour pourquoi ce type
de culture est-il intéressant dans les
Yvelines justement alors comme on disait
avant donc mes grands-parents et mes
parents donc exploités et exploitent
toujours pour mes parents du blé du maïs
de colza de l'orge ce sont les cultures
qu'on maîtrise on sait les faire pousser
sa réussite bien de notaire depuis
maintenant cinq ans j'ai décidé de
lancer la production de légumineuses
pourquoi c'est une nouvelle famille de
culture et de côté agronomique c'est
bien pour le sol plus il y a de familles
différentes mieux c'est pourquoi il y a
moins de salissements il y a moins de
maladies et donc finalement ça permet de
préserver notre environnement et de
préserver nos notaires à côté il y avait
l'attente sociétale qui demande de plus
en plus de légumineuses et donc
finalement les deux volontés se sont
retrouvés et je vous dis on y va et
autour de vous avez fédéré une trentaine
de producteurs du territoire c'est
important de fédérer tout ce monde
pourquoi c'est aussi intéressant de le
fédérer travailler avec plusieurs
producteurs justement on est on est bien
plus fort à plusieurs ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
une nouvelle culture donc on n'est pas
très bien comment faire pousser ses
lentilles
de plus il faut en faire qu'une fois
tous les six ans donc finalement on fait
de petites surfaces et ça produit des
petites quantités et donc le fait d'être
plusieurs permet finalement d'avoir
toute la gamme puisque la gamme est très
large je vais en parler tout à l'heure
et ça permet d'avoir des quantités
satisfaisantes pour répondre à la
demande Illinoise
ma démarche personnelle sur
l'introduction de nouvelles cultures
d'une nouvelle famille finalement mes
voisins l'avaient aussi après il y avait
le souci comment faire pour le vendre
à proximité il y a le souci aussi de
travailler on va dire on a des équation
avec la manière de faire de chaque
producteur qui sont agriculture
biologique de précision et en tout cas
un respect aussi de votre part de cette
manière de faire c'est capital notre
monde producteur ce sont engagés à
produire sur les méthodes virtuelles
pour l'environnement alors il y a le bio
j'en parle pas parce qu'on en parle
énormément mais il y a tout ce qui est
déjà conversion vecteur biologique trois
ans compliqué pour les producteurs donc
on les accompagne nos valoriser leur
production mais il y a aussi tout ce qui
est conservation des sols qui est
complètement méconnu du grand public
mais qui amène beaucoup de bienfaits
films entre environnement
un des exemples c'est on ne tue plus les
vers de terre en travaillant le sol et
on évite finalement que quand il y a des
gros orages toute la bourse retrouve
dans le salon des voisins donc ça a
beaucoup de vertus même si on utilise
toujours un peu de produits de synthèse
il y a la lecture de précision après
l'acteur certifié il y a le 14000 ans
donc c'est en fait de progrès continue
en environnement il faut partir de notre
groupe voilà donc ce sont que des
producteurs qui font un effort vis-à-vis
de l'environnement et qui se remet en
question et qui essaie de faire de mieux
en mieux et donc on parle de culture de
lentilles de poids de grains production
d'huile de farine bah quelle gamme
justement quel type alors l'objectif
c'est que tout ce qu'on produit sur nos
fermes de grandes cultures des Yvelines
finalement puissent se retrouver sur une
assiette de nos voisins donc le blé on
transforme en farine pour faire des
gâteaux du pain faire plein de choses
l'orge on l'a fait maltée et après on
l'avant au microbrasseur afin de la
bière de plus en plus apprécié et on a
de nombreuses microbrastées sur le
territoire une femme micro une fois la
bien obtenue on récupère des drêches
donc finalement c'est toujours la même
orge et c'est vrai si on en fait quoi on
la donne soit en alimentation
pour montrer notre gamme montrer ce
qu'on sait faire donc on est on est fier
des participer et un grand merci
finalement
au département des Yvelines et à la
région de nous accueillir sous le
pavillon Île-de-France qui aura qui sera
sur le hall 7 du salon Paul 7 pavillon
Île-de-France vous y serez sur quel jour
je serai tous les jours sauf le lundi et
le mardi et vous y ajouter quelque chose
oui je vais rajouter autre chose et on
en profite pour lancer notre site
internet donc ça sera samedi le
lancement officiel donc on a refait
notre site internet qui sera une
boutique en ligne où chaque consommateur
pourra finalement voir ce qu'on produit
comment on produit et éventuellement
acheter pour te livrer directement chez
eux ce sera quoi le site internet Willy
pleine de versailles.fr et bien le
message est passé merci Christian Hubert
d'être venu en plateau et je vous
souhaite un très bon son de
l'agriculture donc vous serez présent
vous sur tous l'événement à qui tiendra
du 25 février au 5 mars Porte de
Versailles à Paris merci d'être venu en
plateau et demain nous recevons deux
garantie boucher un qui participe à un
concours sur ce salon de l'agriculture
ne recevront également les délices du
potager à feucherolin qui feront partie
aussi de ces représentants ivillois
nombreux très nombreux sur ce salon de
l'agriculture